[Musique]
plus habitué au romantisme
l'italienne salle de l'opéra de tours se
voulait pour un moment victorieux
s'esquive liturgique royal les
dominicale avec l'été les hommes de jean
baptiste lully et marc antoine
charpentier compositeur aux destins
croisés
j'ai voulu de mettre en miroir le thé
les hommes dans les versions lui c'est
paradoxal on connaît bien les lieux
connaît pas santé des hommes on connaît
moins charpentier mais on connaît très
bien son teaser et donc l'idée c'était
de mettre ces deux oeuvres sur le même
texte en miroir
l es deux parcours sont très
intéressants parce que lui l'italien qui
faire fortune qui est justement atteint
des plus grands honneurs
la cour de louis xiv et charpentier
musiciens français qui lui est parti se
former en italie et qui finalement a
apporté avec lui un style qui est qu'on
pourrait maintenant qualifié de style
plus italien
[Musique]
consonances donnait ainsi au rouge et or
d'école les dernières réseau no son
concert d'automne qui fermait à 6 ans à
colorer baroque et en est ce que ce pays
peut arriver avant le temps à ces la
voyelle carrés sur le temps et le pea
rivard entend consonance en opposition à
dissonances et une formation tourangelle
et s'ils voient des instrus veut se
mêlent avec précision autour d'un même
texte que l'on habile de musique sont
chantés lire le télégramme
c'est clair que lully en aidant une
musique qu'on va dire de célébration du
pouvoir le thé des hommes et un texte de
louanges c'est sûr de célébrations mais
en plus dans son style musical
c'est vraiment une musique de puissance
de pouvoir etc de l'autorité je dirais
un qui rejoint un peu finalement le
message politique aussi que sont que son
bienfaiteur le 14 voulait le faire
presser et charpentier dans une vision
plus intimiste plus plus humaine il n'y
a plus plus touchante
marc antoine charpentier sera sans le
savoir l'ambassadeur de l'europe et de
la télévision
à une époque où l'écran magique était
encore en noir et blanc
[Musique]
avec nous pour rabat pour en parler
alessandro di profus où vous êtes beau
soir l'organisateur de ces concerts
d'automne le bilan est très positif
mais effectivement il me semble mais
c'est vrai que conan pas encore terminé
de de décompter les chiffres donc on va
voir
est ce qu'on sera aussi bon que l'an
dernier parce qu'on avait totalisé 7500
spectateurs donc c'est vraiment vraiment
énorme
là je veux m'en plusieurs fois la salle
le plein et la salle debout ça c'est
effectivement extrêmement important
vraiment l'enthousiasmé du public c'est
quelque chose qui marque et qui m'a
beaucoup touché quand on regarde la
programmation de ces concerts on
remarque la jeunesse des musiciens vous
donner un coup de jeune par les
interprètes mais également par
l'interprétation c'est un petit peu une
réactualisation des oeuvres c'est une
volonté volonté globale
déjà on a c'est vrai qu'on a fait un
tarif il ce moment favorable pour les
jeunes parce que il peut il peut venir
avec 5 euros donc sa veyron c'est
vraiment un tarif pour eux pour coco
sulfureux donc on travaille beaucoup
avec l'université avec le conservatoire
on a lancé un cycle vraiment dédié aux
jeunes donc qu'on appelle le tremplin
qui nous accompagner pendant tout le
festival
et effectivement on retrouve aussi les
jeunes parmi les professionnels donc
dans dans tous les ans semble
effectivement ce sont des ensembles avec
une moyenne d'âge qui peut qui est
parfois voilà plutôt entre 20 et 30 ans
et effectivement comme vous le disiez
aussi à une volonté de dépoussiérer
cette musique avec beaucoup d'énergie
beaucoup de passion hier par exemple
voilà le théâtre de tours était vraiment
a salué avec une grande ovation un
ensemble ils s'appellent la capelle la
méditerranée à qui allait chercher les
musiques que perdu d'aller couvent de
les églises au pérou
donc dans des terres inconnues et c'est
une musique vraiment excellent festive
ex-amant joyeuse donc voilà c'est ça
c'est la marque de fabrique et pardon
des concepts de tonnes de communiquer
cette joie de faire la musique ensemble
donc tour est vraiment une référence en
matière de musique baroque ancien
également
bah tour est une référence ce depuis
longtemps parce qu'effectivement il y
avait des personnalités comme bouc qui
ont beaucoup fait pour la musicologie
pour l'enseignement pour la formation
qui ont créé des ensembles est de plus
en plus il ya des musiciens qui quittent
que les grandes villes notamment paris
pour s'installer ici donc vraiment c'est
devenu une ville dé la musique et des
musiciens est donc évidemment ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on veut mettre en avant
donc chaque année on retrouve les grands
ensembles qui sont basés en touraine
donc le public il est souvent fidèles
qui sont attachés à ces ensembles et
parallèlement effectivement les invités
donc avec les invités de marque au
niveau grande réputation internationale
et qui anime qui enrichissent cette
programmation
merci beaucoup monsieur dit proview
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous